the human brain is not built to deal
with more than about five to nine
options after that the brain just
spaces out you choose nobody hi
i'm dr helen fisher i'm a biological
anthropologist i study love and this is
love support
[Music]
this person calls herself ruth bader
love at first sight is probably bull
right
wrong love at first sight is extremely
easy to explain this is a brain system
it's like the fear system or the anger
system and it can be triggered instantly
you got to be ready for it and we all
carry in our head what i call a love map
an unconscious and conscious list of
what you're looking for in a partner but
the moment comes you're ready to fall in
love you see somebody from across the
crowded room or wherever they fit within
your love map you go over and you speak
to them they smile sweetly at you they
say something that's funny or charming
or interesting and boom instantly
trigger that brain circuitry uh for
romantic love attachment that other
brain system grows slowly you have to
get to know somebody to begin to feel
attachment but romantic love can be
instant yes this is from izzy lean who
created love this is too much to
handle well love evolved for millions of
years we have formed partnerships pair
bonding or monogamy mono means one and
gamma means spouse one spouse that's all
it means to scientists people are also
adulterous but they form partnerships 97
of mammals do not pair up to where
they're young people do it's a hallmark
of the human animal and along with the
evolution of pair bonding came the
evolution of the human brain systems for
the sex drive romantic love and feelings
of deep attachment i and my colleagues
have put 15 people into a brain scanner
who had just been rejected in love and
the brain goes just the wiring just goes
crazy i mean when you're
madly in love with somebody and you've
been dumped it's one of the worst
experiences i mean people pined for love
they live for love they kill for love
and they die for love and i do think
that
it is an addiction because we found
activity in a particular brain region
it's called the nucleus accumbens that
particular brain region is active in all
of the addictions all the substance
addictions all the behavioral addictions
like gambling and it becomes just as
active when you've been rejected in love
and when this person says this is
too much to handle but we all do handle
it the vast majority of us do get over
it and i've been able to prove in the
brain that time does heal because it is
our survival it is a survival mechanism
it evolved millions of years ago and it
will be with us millions of years from
now romantic love is primordial
it's adaptable and it's eternal so this
will always be too much to handle
but we'll do it anyway this person is
skz
is my universe how to try and fall in
love during a pandemic dating apps
aren't really doing it they're doing it
for a lot of people about 40 percent of
singles in america said that they met
their last first date on the internet
here are the two mistakes that they make
perhaps this person is making them too
first mistake is they binge the human
brain is not built to deal with more
than about five to nine options after
that the brain just
spaces out you you choose nobody so the
first thing that you've got to do is
after you've met
nine people and that's what this person
needs to do get off the internet site
get off of it and get to know at least
one of these people better the more you
get to know somebody the better you tend
to like so number one don't binge number
two think of reasons to say yes instead
of no we have this big brain region
linked with negativity bias we're built
to remember the negative and when you
have just met somebody you know so
little about them that you overweight
those few things that you know and so
you'll say oh i don't know she likes
cats i like dogs never going to work get
over it think of reasons to say yes i
call it positive illusions the ability
to overlook what you don't like about
somebody and focus on what you do this
is from somebody called the gin bunny
too can you truly be in love and cheat
alas you can you know these are
different brain systems sex drive and
romantic love are different brain
systems and you can be madly in love
with somebody and also sleep around as a
matter of fact i do think that the brain
is unfortunately built
for both i've looked at adultery in 40
cultures and you see it everywhere in
the world even in places where you could
get your head chopped off for it we seem
to have the ability to be madly in love
with some person and deeply attached to
that person and also sneak around i call
it a dual human reproductive strategy a
tremendous drive to fall in love form a
partnership and have your babies and
also to cheat next up is from rodney j
gavino google search how does attraction
work why him why her
why do you fall in love with one person
rather than another there's all kinds of
cultural reasons that we tend to fall in
love when the timing is right we tend to
fall in love with somebody who's around
proximity is important we tend to fall
in love with somebody from the same
ethnic and socioeconomic background
somebody of the same level of education
and there's four basic brain systems
that each one of them is associated with
a constellation a suite a group of
personality traits dopamine serotonin
testosterone and estrogen systems i
created a questionnaire to see to what
degree you express the traits in all
four of these basic brain systems it's
now been taken by over 15 million people
in 40 countries and i'm able to watch
who's naturally drawn to whom if you're
very high on the traits in the dopamine
system risk taking novelty seeking
curious creative you tend to be drawn to
people like yourself if you are very
high on the traits of the serotonin
system you tend to be traditional
conventional follow the rules respect
authority detail-oriented rather than
theoretical you're also drawn to people
like yourself so if you're very high
testosterone you tend to be analytical
logical direct decisive good at things
like math engineering computers music
music is very structural and you're
drawn to your opposite high estrogen
people and this is men as well as women
many more women in that category they
tend to see the big picture they think
long term
they're very imaginative very good at
reading posture gesture tone of voice we
all express all four systems this is
what the problem is with most
personality questionnaires today they
put you in one bucket or another we
express all four brain systems and the
traits in each but we express some more
than others now there's all kinds of
circumstances where people are drawn to
their opposite in ways because they had
a bad love affair they've been running
around all their lives and now they want
something more stable so they go for the
traditional even if they're very
risk-taking this human variety but the
bottom line is there's patterns to
culture there's patterns to nature and
there's patterns to personality this is
from sad short friend to how does
someone know if they're feeling romantic
or platonic attraction there's a literal
list of traits that are associated with
feelings of romantic love and they are
not associated with platonic attraction
the first thing that happens when you
fall in love is somebody takes on
special meaning everything about them
becomes special the car they drive looks
different from every other car in the
parking lot the house that they live in
the street that they live on the music
that they like when it's a plutonic
attraction not everything is special
about this human being you like them i
mean you're attracted to them you find
them amusing or funny or interested but
you don't they don't you don't you're
not obsessed with them but if you had to
think about one just one trait that is
most distinctive between the two when
you're madly in love with somebody in a
romantic attraction you are obsessed and
in a plutonic attraction you don't think
about them night and day this person is
reprogrammed coach is online dating
killing romance it can't
kill romance this is a basic brain
system it evolved millions of years ago
it's like hunger or thirst or anger or
fear you can't kill romance my next up
is from needa beater i wonder what's
actually going on through our bodies
when we think we're in love like what
chemicals are enhanced i and my
colleagues have put over 100 people into
a brain scanner who were madly in love
the first group were people who were
happily in love the second were a group
of people who were rejected in love and
the third was a group of people who were
in love long term so we put these people
in the brain scanner we had them look at
a photograph of their sweetheart and
also a neutral photograph so we could
compare the brain under both
circumstances and we were able to find
that everybody who's madly loved
rejected in love or in love long term
begins to have activity in a tiny little
factory near the base of the brain
called the ventral take metal area it's
way at the base of the brain and that
brain region actually makes dopamine and
sends dopamine to many brain regions
giving you that focus the motivation the
obsession the craving of intense
romantic love and what's interesting to
me is that little factoring the vta lies
right next to the factory that
orchestrates thirst and hunger thirst
and hunger keep you alive today romantic
love enables you to focus your mating
energy on just one individual at a time
and start the mating process and send
your dna into tomorrow this is from
catch my fly do you believe in soul
mates if so do you believe you can have
more than one yes and yes i do believe
in soul mates i do not believe you can
have more than one at a time so now what
does a soul mate i think what this
person is means is somebody who it's a
true love you're not going to sleep with
other people you're not thinking of
going anywhere you might even consider
dying for him or her it is a very deep
genuine attachment
intense feeling of romantic love and i
think that um this is summed up best by
a poet from the 15th century in india
named kabir the lane of love is narrow
there's room for only one and indeed
when you're madly in love it's with only
one person i do believe you can have a
soul mate i think that you may have a
series of soul mates but i don't think
you can have more than one soul mate at
a time from somebody called dance with
voices why do people associate love with
the heart why not the penis or the
sternum there may be a physiological
reason why it has been associated with
love and that is there's a lot of
characteristics a lot of things happen
when you fall madly in love and one of
them is the heart can really pound when
you're really nervous about something i
mean when you're madly in love not only
do you feel that ecstasy euphoria
sleeplessness loss of appetite obsessive
thinking about the person craving for
emotional union but also all kinds of
physiological responses weakness maybe a
pounding heart it really started in the
1300s with jotto in a painting prior to
that there were a lot of uses of the
shape of the heart in fact as early as
5000 years ago in the indus valley they
were drawing things that looked like the
shape of a heart and at that point it
was the seed of a form of parsley plant
or a an ivy leaf but it became became
associated with romantic love probably
with the painting by jotto in in 1309.
this is from jay at 53k1
i lust hard and lose interest quick
how does that work well they're not
ready to fall in love we've evolved
three distinctly different brain systems
from mating and reproduction one is a
sex drive linked with testosterone in
both men and women the second is
romantic love we've been able to prove
this is linked with the dopamine system
in both men and women that's what gives
you the focus the motivation the
obsession and the third brain system is
attachment that sense of calm and
security you can feel with a long-term
partner and this individual he's in the
lust stage he's not ready to fall in
love you know you have to be ready to
fall in love to actually do it and he's
just experiencing a different brain
system the lust system this question is
from gertig it's a very interesting
question any good data out there on
divorce rates for couples that meet via
online dating sites apparently if you
met somebody online as opposed to
offline you're less likely to divorce
just by a little but you are less likely
to divorce people who date online are
more likely to be fully employed more
likely to have higher education and more
likely to be interested in a committed
partnership this is from reiki array how
can you be in love with somebody and
jealous of them
easily when you're madly in love with
somebody it's called mate guarding other
animals do it too and if you see your
partner beginning to flirt with other
individuals you could lose that partner
you could lose your children you could
lose your house you could lose your
friends you could lose your money i mean
you know the game of love matters this
is from la matina 10. question of the
day this person writes
couples that do this together have 20
more love hormones it's not dirty well i
don't know what this person has in mind
but i would say play when you play with
somebody you're driving up the dopamine
system in the brain and that gives you
focus motivation energy and optimism
play with somebody stay with somebody oh
that's it that's all the questions i
enjoyed answering them thank you for
joining me till next time
you